the bow don't sweat now peace well
you got it beautiful Tony gonna burn my
troubles away
I'm going
the world
hey guys I'm Kate and on this week's mod
of the week we're taking a look at the
m22 16 standalone assault rifle most
weapon mods are Rhys kins but we're
starting to see completely new weapons
make their way into the fallout mod
community this mod created by the
spaceman and Cloud Strife is modeled
after the US Army's m16 the rifle is
fully customizable at your weapon bench
and features an array of receivers
stocks barrels and scopes so you can
change the iconic gun to suit your needs
you won't find this weapon on any Raider
or brotherhood of steel knight so to
access it you have to use your games
console commands and type player dot add
item followed by the item ID the m22 16
does look a little too clean to be
considered a way saunders best friend
but this is exactly the kind of thing
that fits perfectly into the lore of
fallout in fact Fallout New Vegas had a
weapon called the service rifle which
has a similar look although it had
wooden accessories there's an impressive
amount of detail on this weapon the
textures are high resolution with a
small amount of wear to the rifle and
each piece and accessory has been
accurately modeled after their
real-world counterparts and even fires
5.56 caliber rounds just like the real
world m16 so it's fair to say you're not
gonna get a more accurate and loyal
recreation in the world of Fallout the
modifications to the m22 16 adds a nice
balance to the weapon making sure it's
not too weak but gives you the bonus
ability to blow apart super mutants in
one shot
it's also definitely something I could
see the Gunners using so hopefully the
mod creators added into the world soon
if you want to try out this rifle for
yourself you can find the link to the
mod in the description below or you can
search for it on the fallout mod nexus
once you're done filling Raider scum
with lead come back and tell us what you
think of it and if you have any mods
you'd like to see featured tweet them at
us with the hashtag GS fallout until
next week I've been K this has been
GameSpot's fallout mod of the week and
thanks for watching